welcome to my talk on hacking the new
nintendo game and watch super mario
brothers
my name is thomas roth and i'm a
security researcher and trainer from
germany
and you can find me on twitter at git
run ninja and also on youtube at stax
machine
now this year marks the 35th anniversary
of our favorite plumber
super mario and to celebrate that
nintendo launched a new game console
called the nintendo game and watch super
mario brothers
the console is lightweight and looks
pretty nice and it comes pre-installed
with three games and also this nice
animated clock
the three games are super mario brothers
the original nes game
super mario bros 2 the lost levels and
also
a reinterpretation of an old game and
watch game called
ball now as you probably know
this is not the first retro console that
nintendo released
in 2016 they released the nes classic
and 2017 they released the snes classic
now these devices were super popular in
the homebrew community
because they make it really easy to add
additional roms to it
they make it really easy to modify the
firmware and so on
and you can basically just plug them
into your computer install a simple
software and you can do whatever you
want with them
the reason for that is that they run
linux and have
and have a pretty powerful arm processor
on the inside and so it's really
it's really a nice device to play with
and so on
and so when nintendo announced this new
console
a lot of people were hoping for a
similar experience of having a nice
mobile homebrew device
now if you were to make a venn diagram
of
some of my biggest interests you would
have reverse engineering
hardware hacking and retro computing
and this new gaming watch fits right in
the middle of that and so when it was
announced
on the 3rd of september i knew that i
needed to have one of those
and given how hard the nes and the snes
classic
were to buy for a while i pre-ordered it
on like four or five different sites
a couple of which got cancelled but
i was pretty excited because i had three
pre-orders and
it was supposed to ship on the 13th of
november
and so i was really looking forward to
this
and i was having breakfast on the 12th
of november when suddenly the doorbell
rang and
dhl delivered me the new game and watch
one day before the official release
now at that point in time there was no
technical
information available about the device
whatsoever
like if you search for game and watch on
twitter you would only find the
announcements
or maybe a picture of the box of someone
who also received it early
but there were no teardowns no pictures
of the insights
and most importantly nobody hacked had
hacked it yet
and this gave me as a hardware hacker
the kind of unique opportunity to
potentially be the first one to hack
a new nintendo console and so i just
literally dropped everything else i was
doing
and started investigating the device
now i should say that normally i stay
pretty far away from
any new console hacking mainly because
of the piracy issues i don't want to
enable piracy
i don't want to i don't want to
deal with piracy and i don't want to
build tools that enable other people to
pirate stuff
basically but given that on this device
you cannot buy any more games and that
all the games that are on there
were basically already released over 30
years ago
i was not really worried about piracy
and felt pretty comfortable
in sharing all the results of the
investigation
and also the basically the issues we
found
that allowed us to customize the device
and so on
and in this talk i want to walk you
through how we managed to
hack the device and how you can do it at
home using relatively cheap hardware
and yeah hope you enjoy it
now let's start by looking at the at the
device itself
the device is pretty lightweight and
comes with a nicely
sized case and so it really for me it
sits really well in my hand and it has a
nice
320 by 240 lcd display a d-pad
a and b buttons and also three buttons
to switch between
the different game modes on the right
side we also have the power button and
the usbc
port now before you get excited about
the usb port
i can already tell you that
unfortunately nintendo decided to not
connect the data lines of the usb port
and so you can really only use it for
charging also because we are talking
about nintendo here
they use their proprietary tripoint
screws
on the device and so to open it up you
need one of those special tripoint bits
luckily nowadays most bit sets should
have them but it still
would suck if you order your unit and
then you can't open it up because you're
missing a screwdriver
after opening it up the first thing you
probably notice
is the battery and if you've ever opened
up a nintendo switch joycon before you
might recognize the battery because it's
the exact same one
that's used in the joy cons this is very
cool because if down the line like let's
say in two or three years
your battery of your gaming watch dies
you can just go and buy a joy-con
battery
which you can have really cheaply almost
anywhere
next to the battery on the right side we
have a small speaker
which is not very good and underneath we
have the main pcb with the processor the
storage and so on and so forth
let's take a look at those now the main
processor of the device is an stm32h7b0
this is a cortex m7 from st
microelectronics with 1.3 megabytes of
ram
and 128 kilobytes of flush it runs at
280 megahertz and is a pretty beefy
microcontroller
but it's much less powerful than the
processor in the nes or snes classic
like this processor is really just a
microcontroller and so it can't run
linux
it can't run let's say super complex
software instead it will be
it will be programmed in some bare metal
way and so we will have a bare metal
firmware on the device
to the right of it you can also find a
one megabyte spi flash
um and so overall we have roughly 1.1
megabyte of storage on the device
now most microcontrollers are basically
all microcontrollers
have a debugging port and if we take a
look at the pcb
you can see that there are five
unpopulated contacts here
and if you see a couple of contacts that
are not populated close to your cpu
it's very likely that that it's the
debugging part
and luckily the datasheet for the stm32
is openly available
and so we can check the pin outs in the
datasheet
and then use a multimeter to to see
whether these pins are actually the
debugging interface
and turns out they actually are and so
we can find the swd debugging interface
as well as vcc and ground exposed on
these pins
now this means that we can use a
debugger so for example a j-link or an
st-link or whatever
to connect to the device and because the
the contacts are really easy to access
you don't even have to solder like you
can just hook up a couple of test pins
and they will allow you to to easily
hook up your debugger now the problem is
on most devices the debugging interface
will be locked during manufacturing
this is done to prevent people like us
to basically do whatever with the device
and to prevent us from being able to
dump the firmware uh potentially
re-flash it and so on
and so i was very curious to see whether
we can actually connect to the debugging
port
and when starting up j-link and trying
to connect we can see it can
actually successfully connect but when
you take a closer look
there's also a message that the device
is actively protected
this is because the chip the stm3d2 chip
features something called rdp protection
level or readout protection level
this is basically the the security
setting for the debugging interface and
it has
three levels level zero means no
protection is active
level one means that the flash memory is
protected and so we can't dump the
internal flash of the device
however we can dump the ramp contents
and we can also execute code from ram
and then there's also level 2 which
means that all debugging features
are disabled now just because a chip is
in level 2
doesn't mean that you have to give up
for example in our talk wallet.fail a
couple of years ago
we showed how to use fault injection to
bypass
the level 2 protection and downgrade the
chip to level 1.
however on the game and watch we are
lucky and the interface is not fully
disabled
instead it's in level one and so we can
still dump
the ram which is a pretty good entry
point even though
we can't dump the firmware yet now
having dumped the ram of the device i
was pretty curious to see
what's inside of it and one of my
suspicions was that potentially
the emulator that's hopefully running on
the device
loads the original super mario brothers
rom into ram
and so i was wondering whether maybe we
can find the rom that the device uses
in the ram dump and so i open up the ram
dump in a
in a hex editor and i also open up the
original super mario brothers rom
in a second window in a hex editor and
try to find
different parts of the original rom in
the ram dump and it turns out that
yes the nes rom is loaded
into ram and it's always at the same
address and so it's probably like during
boot up it gets copied into ram
or something along those lines and so
this is pretty cool to know because it
tells us
a couple of things first off we know now
that the debug port is enabled and
working
but that it's unfortunately at rdp level
one and so we can only dump the
the ram and we also know that the nes
rom is loaded into ram
and this means that the device runs a
real nes emulator
and so if we get aki we can for example
just replace the rom that is used by
by the device and play for example our
own nes game
next was time to dump the flash chip of
the device for this i'm using a device
called mini pro and i'm using one of
these really useful
syc8 clips and so these ones you can
simply clip
onto the flash chip and then dump it now
one warning though the flash chip on the
device is running at 1.8 volts and so
you want to make sure that your
programmer
also supports 1.8 volt operation if you
accidentally try to read it out at 3.3
volts
you will break your flash trust me
because it happened to me on one of my
units
now with this flash dump from the device
we can start to analyze it
and what i always like to do first is
take a look at the entropy
or the randomness of the flash dump and
so using bin walk with the dash
uppercase e option
we get a nice entropy graph and in this
case you can see we have a very high
entropy over almost the whole flash
contents
and this mostly indicates that the flash
contents are encrypted
it could also mean compression but if
it's compressed you would
often see more like dips in the entropy
and in this case it's one very high
entropy stream
we also notice that there are no
repetitions whatsoever
which also tells us that it's probably
not like a simple xor based encryption
or so
and instead something like aes or or
something similar
but just because the flash is encrypted
doesn't mean we have to give up on the
contrary
i think now it starts to get interesting
because you actually have a challenge
and it's not just plug and
plug and play so to say one of the
biggest questions i had
is is the flash actually verified like
does the device boot even though the
flash has been modified
because if it does this would open up a
lot of
attack vectors basically as you will see
and so to to verify this i basically try
to put
zeros in random places in the flash
image and so
i put some at address 0 so i'm at hex
2000 and so on
and then i checked whether the device
would still boot up and with
most flash modifications it would still
boot just fine
this tells us that even though the flash
contents are encrypted
they are not validated they are not
checksum or anything and so the device
and so we can potentially trick the
device
into accepting a modified flash image
and this is really important to know as
you will see in a couple of minutes
my next suspicion was that maybe the nes
rom we see in ram
is actually loaded from the external
flash
and so to to find out whether that's the
case
i again took the flash and i inserted
zeros
at multiple positions in the flash image
flashed that over booted up the game
dumped the ram
and then compared the nes rom that i'm
now dumping from ram
with the one that i dumped initially and
checked whether they are equal
because my suspicion was that maybe i
can
i can overwrite a couple of bytes in the
encrypted flash
and then i will modify the nes rom and
after
doing this for like i don't know half an
hour i got lucky
and i modified four bytes in the flash
image and four bytes in the ram
uh sorry in the rom that was loaded into
ram changed
and this tells us quite a bit it means
that the rom is loaded
from flash into ram and that the
the flash contents are not validated
and what's also important is that we we
changed four bytes in the flash
and now four bytes in the decrypted
image changed
and this is very important to know
because if we take a look at what we
would expect to happen when we when we
change the flash contents
there are multiple outcomes and so for
example here we have these by spyflash
contents on the left
and the ram contents on the right and so
the ram contents are basically the
decrypted version
of the spyflash contents now let's say
we change four bytes in the encrypted
flash image to zeros
how would we expect the ram contents to
change for example if we would see that
now
16 bytes in the ram are changing
this means that we are potentially
looking at
an encryption algorithm such as aes in
electronic codebook mode
because it's a block based encryption
and so if we change
four bytes in the input data a block
size in this case 16 bytes in the output
data would change
the next possibility is that we change
four bytes in the spy flash
and all data afterwards will be changed
and in this case
we would look at some kind of chaining
cipher such as aes in the cbc mode
however if we change 4 bytes in the spy
flash
and only 4 bytes in the ram changed we
are looking
at at something such as aes in counter
mode
and to understand this let's take a
better look at how aes and ctr works
aes ctr works by having your clear text
and xoring it
with an aes encryption stream that is
generated from
a key a nonce and a counter algorithm
now the aes stream that will be used to
x or your clear text
will always be the same if key and nonce
is the same
this is why it's super important that if
you use aesctr
you always select a unique nonce for
each encryption
if you encrypt similar data with the
same nonce
twice large parts of the resulting
ciphertext will be the same
and so the clear text gets xored with
the asctr stream
and then we get our ciphertext
now if we know the clear text as we do
because the clear text is
the rom that is loaded into ram and we
know
the ciphertext which we do because it's
the contents of the encrypted flash we
just dumped
we can basically reverse the operation
and as a result we get the aes ctr
stream that was used to
encrypt the flash and now this means
that we can take for example a custom
rom
xor it with the asctr stream we just
calculated
and then generate our own encrypted
flash image for example with a modified
rom
and so i wrote a couple of python
scripts to to try this
and after a while i was running hacked
super mario brothers instead of super
mario brothers
so woohoo we hacked the nintendo game
and watch one day before the official
release
and we can install modified super mario
brothers roms
now you can find the scripts that i used
for this on my github
so it's in a repository called game and
watch hacking
and i was super excited because it mean
it meant that i succeeded and that i
basically hacked a nintendo console
one day before the official release
unfortunately i finished the level but
toad wasn't
as excited he told me that unfortunately
our firmware
is still in another castle and so on the
monday
after the launch of the device i teamed
up with conrad backman a hardware hacker
from sweden who i met at the previous
congress
and we started chatting and throwing
ideas back and forth and so on
and eventually we noticed that the
device has a special
ram area called itcm ram which is a
tightly coupled instruction ram
that is normally used for very high
performance
routines such as interrupt handlers and
so on and so it's in a very fast
ram area and we realized that we never
actually looked at the contents of that
itcm ram
and so we dumped it from the device
using the debugging port
and it turns out that this itcm ram
contains arm code
and so again the question is where does
this arm code come from does it maybe
just like the nes rom come from the
external flash
and so um basically i repeated the whole
the whole thing that we also did with
the nes rom and it just put zeros at the
very beginning of the encrypted flash
rebooted the device and dumped the itcm
rom
and i got super lucky on the first try
already the itcm contents changed
and because the itcm contains code not
just data so earlier we only had the the
nes rom which is just data
but this time the ram contains code this
means
that with the same xor trick we used
before we could inject
custom itcm code into the external flash
which would then be loaded into ram when
the device boots
and because it's it's a persistent
method
we can then reboot the device and let it
run without the debugger connected
and so whatever code we load into this
itcm area
will be able to actually read the flash
and so we could potentially write some
code
that gets somehow called by the firmware
and then copies the internal flash
into ram from where we then can retrieve
it
using the debugger
now the problem is let's say we have a
custom payload
in somehow in this itcm area
we don't know which address of this itcm
code
gets executed and so we don't know
whether the firmware will jump to
address 0 or address to 100 or whatever
but there's a really simple trick to
still build a successful payload and
it's called a knob slide
a knob or no operation is an instruction
that simply does nothing
and if we fill most of the itcm ram with
knobs and put our payload at the very
end we build something that is basically
an
upslide and so when the cpu
indicated by mario here jumps to a
random address in that whole knob slide
it will start executing knobs knobs
knobs knobs and slide down into our
payload and execute it
and so even if mario jumps right in the
middle of the knob slide
he will always slide down the slide and
end up in our payload
and conrad wrote this really really
simple payload which is only like 10
instructions which basically just copies
the internal flash into ram
from where we can then retrieve it using
the debugger
so woohoo super simple exploit we have a
full firmware backup and a full flash
backup and now we can really fiddle with
everything on the device and we've
actually released tools
to do this yourself and so if you want
to backup your nintendo game and watch
you can just go
onto my github and download the game and
watch backup repository
which contains a lot of information on
how to back it up
it does it does check something and so
on to ensure that you
don't accidentally brick your device and
you can easily
backup the original firmware install
homebrew and then
always go back to the original software
we also have an awesome
support community on discord and so if
you ever need help
you you will i think you will find
success there
and so far we haven't had a single
bricked game and watch
and so looks to be pretty stable
and so i was pretty excited because the
quest was over
or is it if you
ever claim on the internet that
you successfully hacked an embedded
device there will
be exactly one response and one response
only
but does it run doom literally my
twitter dms my youtube comments and even
my friends were spamming me
with the challenge to get doom running
on the device but to get doom running
we first needed to bring up all the
hardware
and so we basically needed to create a
way to develop and load homebrew onto
the device
now luckily for us most of the
components on the board
are very well documented and so there
are no nda components and so for example
the processor has an open reference
manual and open source library to use it
the flash is a well-known flash chip
and so on and so forth and there are
only a couple of very proprietary or
custom components and so for example the
lcd on the device is proprietary and we
had to basically sniff the
spi bus that goes to the display
to basically decode the the
initialization
of the of the display and so on and
after a while we had
the full hardware running we had lcd
support we had audio support steep
support buttons
and even flashing tools that allow you
to simply use an swd debugger
to dump and rewrite the external flash
and you can find all of these things on
our github
now if you want to mod your own game and
watch all you need
is a simple debugging adapter such as a
cheap
three dollar st-link a trading one sr or
a real st-link device
and then you can get started we've also
published a base
project for anyone who wants to get
started with building their own games
for the game and watch and so it's
really simple
it's just a frame buffer you can draw to
input is really simple and so on
and as said we have a really helpful
community
now with all the hardware up and running
i could finally start porting doom
now i started by looking around for
other parts of doom 2 and stm32
and i found this project by floppis
called stm32doom
now the issue is stm32doom is
designed for a board with 8 megabytes of
ram
and also the data files for doom were
stored on an external usb
drive on our platform we only have
1.3 megabytes of ram 128 kilobytes of
flash
and only one megabyte of external flash
and we have to fit
all the level information all the code
and so on in there
now the doom level information is stored
in so-called
wad what where's all my data files
and these data files contain the sprites
the textures the levels and so on
now the watt for doom 1 is roughly 4
megabytes in size
and the what for doom 2 is 40 megabytes
in size
but we only have 1.1 megabyte of storage
plus we have to fit all the code in
there so obviously
we needed to find a very very small doom
watt and as it turns out there's a thing
called
mini watt which is a minimal doom iwad
which is basically all the bells and
whistles
stripped from the wad file and
everything replaced by
simple outlines and so on and while it's
not pretty
i was pretty confident that i could get
it working as it's only 250 kilobytes
of storage down from 14 megabytes
now in addition to that a lot of stuff
on the chocolate doom port itself had to
be changed and so for example i had to
rip out all the file handling and add a
custom file handler
i had to add support for the game and
watch lcd button import support
and i also had to get rid of a lot of
things to get it
running somewhat smoothly and so for
example the infamous wipe effect had to
go
and i also had to remove sound support
now
the next issue was that once it was
compiling
it simply would not fit into ram and
crash all the time
now on the device we have roughly 1.3
megabytes of ram in different ram
areas and for example just the frame
buffer that we obviously need
takes up 154 kilobytes of that
then we have 160 kilobytes of
initialized data
320 kilobytes of uninitialized data and
a ton of dynamic allocations that are
done by chocolate doom
and these dynamic allocations were a
huge issue because
the chocolate doom source code does a
lot of small allocations
which are only used for temporary data
and so they get
freed again and so on and so your
dynamic memory
gets very very fragmented very quickly
and so eventually there's
just not enough space to for example
initialize the level
and so to fix this i took the chocolate
doom
code and i changed a lot of the dynamic
allocations to static allocations
which also had the big advantage of
making
the error messages by the compiler much
more meaningful because it would
actually tell you
hey this and this data does not fit into
ram
and eventually after a lot of trial and
error and copying as
many of the original assets as possible
into
the minimal iwad i got it
i had doom running on the nintendo game
and watch super mario brothers
and i hopefully can't the internet gods
that forced me to do it
now unfortunately the usb port is
physically not connected
to the processor and so it will not be
possible to hack the device simply by
plugging it into your computer
however it's relatively simple to do
this using one of these
usb debuggers now the most requested
type of homebrew software
was obviously emulators and i'm proud to
say that by now we actually have
kind of a large collection of emulators
running on the nintendo gaming watch and
it all started with conrad beckman
discovering the retro gold project which
is an emulator collection
for a device called the odroid go and
the odroid go
is a small handheld with similar input
and size constraints
as the nintendo game and watch and so
it's kind of
cool to port this over because it it
basically
already did all of the hard work so to
say and
retro go comes with emulators for the
nes
for the game boy and the gamer color and
even for the sega master system and the
sega game gear
and after a couple of days conrad
actually was able to show off
his nes emulator running zelda
and other games such as contra and swan
on the nintendo gaming watch
this is super fun and initially we only
had really a basic emulator that
you know could barely play and we had a
lot of frame drops we didn't have nice
scaling
vsync and so on but now after a couple
of weeks
it's really a nice device to use and to
play with
and so we also have in game boy emulator
running and so you can play your
favorite
game boy games such as pokemon super
mario land and so on
on the nintendo game and watch if you
own the corresponding rom backups
and we also experimented with different
scaling algorithms to make the most
out of the screen and so you can
basically change the scaling algorithm
that is used for the display
depending on what you prefer and you
could even change the palette for the
different games
we also have a nice game chooser menu
where which allows you to basically have
multiple roms on the device that you can
switch
between we have save state support and
so you if you turn off the device
it will save wherever you left off and
you can even come back
to your save game once the battery run
out you can find the source code for all
of that
on the retro go repository from conrad
and it's really really awesome
other people build for example emulators
for the chip 8 system
and so the chip 8 emulator comes with a
nice collection of
small arcade games and so on and it's
really fun
and really easy to develop for and so
really give this a try if you own a game
and watch
and want to try homebrew on it
team sherwin is even working on an
emulator for the original game and watch
games and so this is really cool because
it basically
turns the nintendo game and watch into
an emulator for all game and watch games
that were ever released
and what was really amazing to me is how
the community came together
and so we were pretty open about the
progress on twitter
and also conrad was twitch streaming a
lot of the process
and we opened up a discord where people
could join who were interested in
hacking on the device
and it was amazing to see what came out
of the community and so for example
we now have a working storage upgrade
that works both with homebrew but also
with the original firmware
and so instead of one megabyte of
storage you can have 60 megabytes of
flash
and you just need to to replace a single
chip which is pretty
easy to do then for understanding the
full hardware
daniel cuthbert and daniel padilla
provided us with high resolution x-ray
images
which allowed us to fully understand
every single connection even
of the bga parts without desoldering
anything
then jake little of upcycle electronics
traced on the x-rays and also using a
multimeter
every last trace on the pcb and he even
created a schematic of the device which
gives you all the details you need when
you want to program something or so
and what's really really fun senator van
der wehl for example even created a
custom backplate and now there are even
project that projects that try to
replace the original pcb
with a custom pcb with an fpga and an
esp32
and so it's really exciting to see what
people come up with
now i hope you enjoyed this talk and i
hope to see you on our discord if you
want to join the fun
and thank you for coming